bonsoir c'est olivier de kersauson un
enfant et ludivine sagnier pratique
ludivine sagnier donkey l'une des huit
femmes de françois ozon qui est la
cadette de la bande voilà alors eve
angeli bonsoir de révélation francophone
de l'année aux nrj music awards le 21
janvier 2002 d'ailleurs votre premier
album qui s'appelle m mois a eu un très
bon accueil
on retrouve dans cet album avant de
partir elle qui n'est pas du tout
consacrer à une autre fille
mais à la drogue exactement si j'ai bien
que tu as plus dur droit que vous n'avez
jamais connu
non non justement pas moi mais c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet qui m'a quand
même beaucoup touché par rapport à un
livre que j'avais lu sur une jeune
drogué qui s'appelle l'herbe bleue si
vous connaissez tous cas je vous le
conseille c'est un livre très poignant
il m'avait tellement marqué que j'aime
mon manager et auteur compositeur michel
rostain de me faire un texte sur ce
sujet et voilà l'histoire est le nouveau
single s'appelle c'est pour ça alors
vous êtes né à sète en 1981 f c'est
votre deuxième prénom votre mère des
données ce deuxième prénom à cause de
eve ruggieri et votre vrai prénom c'est
vanessa avoue commencer à chanter vous
aussi là c'est comme chamfort qui
commence le piano à l'âge de 3 ans vous
c'est l'âge de 3 ans vous faites vos
premières chansons 1 à 7 ans en premier
karaoké et vous chantez pourvu qu'elles
soient douces
je me foutais un peu
je sors pas
ce n'est pas son égal
c'est pas du tout satisfait pas tiré
c'était un bon choix
ça se prépare ça se fête
j'adhère totalement à
ton geste envers michael blanc et comme
omar vient d'acheter le homard il va
manquer quelque chose dans le stock je
m'étais dit que peut-être que le premier
costard du big il pouvait faire quelque
chose merci beaucoup
alors
sur la river
de poser la merci et
je ne veux pas je veux pas te rend plus
l'émission mais simplement qu'ils de ma
génération ici n'a pas fumé un pétard
dans sa vie qui n'a pas fumé pétards
j'ai passé dix ans sous les tropiques au
sort tu me sors tout
et fumer un pétard on peut tomber c'est
bien traficoter faux pas mais de la
peine de mort et prison à perpétuité
chez beaucoup mon collègue voilà bisous
c'est mon cher contre et salut à tous
merci
c'est sympa merci vincent lagaf donc
désormais vous pouvez acheter le costume
de vincent lagaf les enchères commencent
merci au profit de michaël blanc dont
nous parlerons tout à l'heure voilà
alors on continue avec vous il faut que
j'évite donc quand vous avez sept ans
vous faites votre premier karaoké vous
chantez pourvu qu'elles soient douces de
mylène farmer
ah oui mylène farmer qui est vraiment
encore aujourd'hui mon idole de toujours
et j'espère j'espère vraiment m'y
attendais vous connaissez les paroles
vous avez lu les paroles
oui c'est vrai que pour mon âge c'était
un petit peu chaud je reconnais ne
savait pas encore cerveau en marche
level 2 premières scènes à saison vous
chantez ziggy de starmania à redessan
près de nîmes dans une fête de la
musique
donc voila vous continuez et là
découvert par graines de stars comme
jennifer d'ailleurs de star académie
aussi oui c'est un peu différent
ouais un petit peu alors avant de partir
a été quand même classé quatrième au top
j'ai déjà vendu un million d'albums ce
qui fait pas mal de pognon non à ça va
mais c'est vrai que ça commence surtout
de mon âge à faire ne serait ce qu'un
bar album c'est vous fait un million de
france pas ma belle truc c'est qu'on
sait pas combien de temps ça va durer
donc c'est vrai que je préfère mettre de
côté parce qu'aussi bien en deux ans je
serai plus là donc je suis assez
sérieuse je claque pas tout ah oui oui
place et où cet argent en banque au
monde est d'accord
maintenant je fais pas la bourse mais
c'est comme ça et en actions vous êtes
célibataire
non c'est fini ce nom je dis ça parce
que vous avez été longtemps sceptique
sur l'amour vous pensez que l'amour en
fait c'était une fiction inventée par
les adultes un peu comme dieu vous dites
c'est exactement ça disais dans mes
pensées vous êtes bien renseigné sheva
c'est vrai nom c'est vrai bain quand
j'étais ado en fait j'avais l'impression
de ne pas trouver mon âme soeur et moi
c'était vraiment mon but parce que
j'étais très fleur bleue très romantique
et je me suis cassé les dents plusieurs
fois donc je me suis dit soit c'est une
fiction soit c'est quelque chose que les
gens se sont vraiment inventé pour
sentir bien comme dieu c'est une
croyance et en fait on le voit que dans
les films que dans les belles histoires
dans les romans et ça y est j'y croyais
plus et puis à 18 ans un petit oiseau
est arrivé et voilà
et
vous marier non par contre j'suis pas
pour le mariage vous êtes d'accord avec
kersauson et pense exactement ça ah bon
l'idée mais on croirait pas en être
aussi délicate mois nous avait dit que
en fait on reste marié parce que divorcé
c'est compliqué j'ai connu des cas dans
mes proches où on reste avec la personne
même si on sait que c'est pas la bonne
juste parce que c'est compliqué toutes
les démarches et puis c'est fatiguant on
n'a peut-être pas envie d'affronter un
divorce par rapport à ses enfants à ses
amis non moi je m'attache pas je
préfèrerais rester libre comme l'air et
vu mon métier en plus c'est quand même
un petit peu mieux que choix même si je
suis avec quelqu'un je me sens libre
vous êtes ultra possessive à vous êtes
très très jalouse je supporte pas en
fait de me sentir délaissés et rejetée à
partir du moment où je donne mon coeur à
quelqu'un j'attends à ce qu'il me donne
le sien et ç'a vraiment été bon même si
je mets la liberté j'ai beau et alors
vous dites si je le trouve au lit avec
une autre jeu l'assassinent ouais ouais
j'suis un peu courte avec moi je suis
fait un bleu puis voilà des fois chien
pas tant que ça non je suis pas aussi
jaloux ce que ça si vous trouvez le vis
avec un mec là je rentre dans l'émission
bon et comme c'est la première fois
qu'on se voit faire une interview
première fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
premier souvenir
premier signe est je pense que ça serait
vraiment ma première scène en fait tout
simplement parce que ça a été beaucoup
de stress pour moi et je m'en rappelle
encore donc c'est vraiment le souvenir
qui me reviendrait alors que chez son
premier objet fétiche
ben en fait c'est un grigri que j'ai
toujours et que j'ai trouvé il ya à peu
près trois ans avec l'homme avec qui je
suis aujourd'hui on la trouvait au bord
de la route et on a senti vu ce que
c'était ce que c'était une matière un
petit peu c'est quoi c'est quoi un petit
peu comme la sorcellerie
je veux parce que c'est ce que j'ai peur
que ça marche plus après m'être de
matières voyez comme les dents des trucs
comme ça mais d'animal c'est pas un truc
d'êtres humains qu'on a trouvé et c'est
une matière vivante en fait qu'on a
trait au bord de la route et c'était pas
celle du tout c'est pour sa couleur
amassé 1 je tiens à préciser ces
patients latex non non non je dirai pas
ce que c'est parce que je suis très
superstitieuse mais voilà c'est ça c'est
un grigri en fait que je mets dans une
petite boîte donc sceptique comme ça
vous avez là non par contre je perds
tout donc tous mes trucs porte bonheur
tous mérité que j'élève sur la barre
mais je me mets en relation avec eux
voilà premier péché franchement je suis
tellement de sage mois
ouais je n'aime pas l'alcool on va dire
c'est cigarette ou simplement quand
j'avais 14 ans puisque le reste tout ce
qui est c'est que je veux dire c'est pas
dépêcher pour moi quand même quelqu'un
qu'on est bien avec lui c'est pas un
péché donc je parlerai pas de ça tout
seul ça a pêché non conflit on va se
dire que non j'étais rekom olivier chez
les curés donc pour nous tous tes péchés
n'est-ce pas tout ce qui apporte du
bonheur est pêché voilà c'est ce
candidat
d
oui paix chez vous j'ai cambrioler une
maison quand j'avais 8 ans un accord
première belle robe première belle robe
vraiment la première très très belle
c'était dans le métier quand j'ai fait
une cérémonie
c'était une remise de prix en fait
c'était comme les nrj music awards mais
une autre chaîne
donc vous savez pas quoi mais j'avais
vraiment mal de dire le monde des autres
chaînes je préfère pas quand même à bord
je sens que je vais faire le show
business maintenant les discussions des
chaînes concurrentes chichi ça j'ai
trouvé dire tous couvrir ça ici m6 se
voir mais voilà premier baiser premier
baiser j'avais 12 ans et je peux dire
son nom c'était yoann et ça s'est très
bien passé enfin j'étais vraiment excité
je me rappelle que quand on a commencé à
s'embrasser en était debout et à la fin
j'ai ouvert les yeux et j'étais en fait
à six ans les marges escaliers parce
qu'on était à l'arrêt bus et donc je
sais pas comment je me suis retrouvé à
six comme ça mais il a dû se passer un
tourbillon et qui m'a fait tomber quoi
c'est assez impressionnant avec la
langouste en allemand avec la en voyant
ces patients là l'an passé quand on
mettait pas la langue de suite à l'idée
on ne met pas la langue
premier flirt poussé premier faire
pousser je devais avoir dix sept ans et
c'était en fait dans une ruelle juste en
face de chez moi donc je me rappelle que
je devais rentrer et ma mère était au
balcon et elle disait je l'entendais
dire à mon père mais qu'est ce qu'elle
fait est dors et déjà être là et du coup
moi ça m'a excité forcément de savoir
mes parents me chercher et on s'est mis
dans que contre la rue fin contre le mur
et là c'est vrai que ça a été la
première fois que c'était un peu plus et
mais justement on n'est pas passé à
l'acte c'est première fois alors très
très poussées voilà n'est pas plus ou
moins première fois avec un garçon 18
ans donc c'est qu'un an après la
première fois poussé et c'est toujours
le même avec son fidèle tout ceci c'est
incroyable les premières fois avec une
fille
jamais un bon jeu que 21 ans le meilleur
est à venir je plaisante
trois jeunes et non plus j'aime c'est
beaucoup de choses à découvrir
jean faure à vous raconter ma vie et
fait des découvertes
premier chagrin d'amour
j'en ai pas mal peut-être il a commencé
dernier treize ans après que j'ai eu mon
premier gars à toute tentative de
suicide jamais c'est pas très grave
alors finalement non ça va je m'en
remets toujours premiers valium témesta
lexomil jamais non pas de drogue jamais
pas même pas de juin rien même pas la
drogue douce on va dire oui j'oubliais
première infidélité
oui c'est vrai qu'avant ben justement
c'était à me 17 ans il m'est arrivé
carrément de sortir avec 3 mais quand
même tour mais je les sentais que
c'était ma dit retro satana ils ne
savaient pas heureusement donc ça va
gérer ça le week-end
elle et moi
pour nous aussi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu